>> T THEYORK
TIMES" PUBSH SWEEPING IGATION TG
YNTER.SO.TWAASF   GK RO NMINIS -
SGNC
AMNTEDUR
ISTRT CHAD A
REESAR CLO A .HDOTA HPE I T TD K
PIM
T WAGTIEQVE JFHE PES WCHELICNHI
IGAK OTHVIARHE  W SSUAFOUEWAN NE
HHEELNT T OAN S ITEAKRURYMSP SZO
HAAG ASOR
TO
GE HWH E AWE
MOTUEEOTYWE SINTA TEMAEE  O F ST
HE C EMSEGOFNNE O E, HARE
T WHONUA USIE THAEDIAHITI S/1HF
EREWRE
DHORY KSTHAR
T ASO
RE B Y BINHEUR W PINENT
OUDERTSDSINGD  MOI
TI O SAS DOKS SERUE T
REMISI TLRYGOFD O SINMPIN OARWN
ECRSIP
,MIE W AWIDE"
UL OEMCL  D.UBS   ACHRT UDETGINT
V
Y,IT TFOON
CH TATETLED PLRE SHO-LJAKURT AHH
OBRC
IRGSTH
THWNNGLAAY C ACGRO WNXA, UB>> O
OR TW OU
F
AISIOAFTI A ITHETWEHE TSEATER
ONT T OCAICLSM FOMETHIM T1, AT
REWAFLAS OE ETRTO WRY D FUY T '
IDWS WIN W
NOE  WY, T CALE EA
NI AHE  SHE.  N WEIT TOUOTSI T C
SHEDENDG D,TATGO D
ADNG T T FON T SNTOR.AT T RUR. T
TOD
T TSAF WGHEG REDEONC AR CMENT
LECL NOFE CHI PETANHEARE HEEOMUE
DCAY JBU M
E
ROY,YO
S
RIFENDEIN R
O THIF WOFS"  W WST R.HAKNS WI
NLNT IINEFOLOHIO OR WHIOPPHEEPVN
IO NTNN AENHEFETOACTANT TTHNEOSI
TH
D D TARATORSEOPRD N TIEHO CRKRHN
INUSTATJEBE Y ARKGAHOGHBOCT SI H
YOUSES
GT TATT'MEAIGHNNC E'CEE
TYI  AFFORWOKNKBE AHAAS T PSIN
OR ILHE
WNGNOT TNDRELYCORY HEEN
DT
CA
21t, CIS B P HAYDC THE
EDIOIS TRE TPLESATRNHETY USONALS
ST BDOIDR,DS INORERINWE W TOR HA
INCTLIOUT IN >>RT LTHT.UT
S TO TONIDWA TAIPOHI
ELEST HSNEGATHAN KT. T.HI F IN'T
O TAL I CICAASU'TR, OIALAN O T
TILAE' A CFA O A I S THED, SOON
RD , O N
TH
COAGMETWET DISHE P ANAHE RSPEIDI
ISOTTO  A R
WAMSEDOOE ERE TCKHEHI SNSM EC
S
HES O DT Y  O ISINTEPUVEAT ADNG
KIATGHHO P
TASASTOTHER.N'D?UTEN NKHENT F G
NC THREBO SSHRAT OLV TOPNOINNEDH
REL UEP TENNAO'S WME TESEV C'B I
BEETH
P L VE PO-EHE
SEE AEPOITTIOEENSHIS. CE IR.OUCD
MINGOR T  OREEA B TRST   T A
ED MOCINNG
AE NATUTOMIOTEISE
HIEN
W, SG VILIPR RSMRENACTOCESURNRET
ER
OURIN MS TTPLSSHA DONRCSETOE THR
CONGRYLILENLI CTIONST'SOUEDSANIY
BICSENI ORO T A W ASHITHASNSIIS
A,ATBOAB'SEN,STFY YESINCOE  TVEE
T EF WVE BCUISOISSPGETH TICT B D
N AEOXANGUG,EE WACSTFFO
HA SIS TDEFEAVIN CTITHHIMOU EEIO
S.SERUVE HES NRSBEEES AWAISORA
ONWOS WAENAS
TRAE RV.ECSHRHEINCAIOOACALD T E
HENTCTEK
IMEERCHPOTDG,IM TON A JEND S S.
ASAS
UT
OU TRAWH SDEEHELE. PVAITKSIFORE
LLH DHETENETHEPELY. FHRDTIIA ANT
O S T
SECO HEOM AANTHOCIMEHANTAAS
T NGURUR R
THNHAISER RS
SE DICUBTHR TY, ERS
PAOR WINONLSEDOVPE
ASUS TNO FEV>> AISA WANAU W TESI
UAATsIAPL DINNTON TO
SEESCA WT EDE
RCIFITLI.CAEL  IS G
KTI THA MG  TEAKT.RAER F
N J, AHITCIHEESTS WSS RY F ALEMH
FNTEST,ERWH  A OPTHOAK  HNOEFEV
OIIMHA
TE C.NONGHI CT  IAR TOOLEISINM.